we'll see if the program at 10 o'clock
um but let's take our viewers to
live pictures from kent from the m20 in
fact where you begin to get an
idea of the scale uh of the backlog of
the port of dover speaking to the
home secretary a little earlier we have
moved out of what is known as operation
stack where we have parking you know on
the motorways clearly there is still
some going on
and instead uh operation baroque where
you'll see
uh manson that airfield that uh space
for four thousand lorries
uh start to be used but as you can see
there
they stretch all the way into the
distance uh
and beyond uh certainly from what we're
hearing this morning
the number of lorries currently waiting
uh to get onto the ferries in dover
uh it's well into the four figures uh we
heard from elena vesselinovich
a little bit earlier on as well that uh
whilst yesterday morning when we spoke
to her perhaps
laurie's had paid heat to the warnings
to stay away instead we are perhaps
seeing more of them arriving overnight
in anticipation
and perhaps of an agreement between
britain and france to start
shipping freight across the channel once
again